une centaine de mètres de marche le long
des rails à partir de la gare centrale
et nous y voilà
l'entrée du tunnel du mont royal est
situé sous la place ville marie
jusqu'à la fin des années 50 on pouvait
d'ailleurs voir arriver ici les traits
au centre ville avant que le tunnel ne
disparaisse pour toujours avec la
construction de l'édifice phare de
montréal aujourd'hui les lieux ont bien
changé à la surface mais sont restés les
mêmes sous terre tunnel a été creusé à
main d'homme avec l'aide d'équipements à
vapeur sa construction a eu lieu de 1912
à 1918 en pleine guerre mondiale ce
chantier où ils sont arrivés à quelques
centimètres l'un de l'autre leurs tics
partait du nord et du sud
alors c'est un chantier qui devait bien
plein fixé bien déroulée la caisse de
dépôt à payer 125 millions de dollars au
réseau de transport métropolitain pour
acheter la ligne de train vers deux
montagnes et le tunnel elle doit
maintenant préparer l'arrivée de son
rêve ces infrastructures qui est
construite dans le rock sera à peu près
tout sa langue a donc sonné faux socios
qui a pratiquement pas bougé depuis
de plus sa construction un deuxième
puits de ventilation est à faire il
faudra remplacer les systèmes
d'éclairage et de communication
évidemment il faudra aussi construire
les deux nouvelles gares pour lesquelles
les travaux de surface ont déjà commencé
celle d'édouard montpetit et celle de
mcgill college situé à quelques
centaines de mètres de la place ville
marie
alors nous sommes hissés à l'emplacement
exact où sera construite à partir de
janvier 2020 la future station mcgill
durée alors tous à des deux côtés de la
voie ferrée va être ouvert pour faire
place au quai les gens qui vont prendre
leur mi6 vont pouvoir arriver à
l'université de montréal
trois minutes plus tard mes étudiants
qui sont qui habite à brassard
actuellement ça leur prend environ une
heure une heure et quart venir à
l'université mémorial
renseigne avec leurs ennemis vont être
là en moins de 20 minutes pour la
station de l'université de montréal
on devra excavés l'équivalent d'un
édifice de 20 étages pour se rendre au
tunnel toute l'infrastructure qui est en
dessous va être incroyable qui
représentent des défis techniques
importants on est à trente mille mètres
cube de rock s'est énormément de roche
qu'on doit sortir de la montagne alors
on se trouve maintenant sous le campus
de l'université mcgill
ici même vous le voyez les deux voix se
rend compte donc les trains qui vont
vers le nord et puis vers le sud quatre
kilomètres et demi plus loin il y à la
sortie du tunnel mont-royal dans ville
mont royal
actuellement une soixantaine de trains
qui passent ici chaque jour à compter de
2022 avec le rsa sera près de 600 trains
par jour